roads where we're dying we don't need
roads when Back to the Future 2 came out
we all thought we'd be dressing like
this and commuting to work like this all
by the year 2015. Well we skipped the
fashion and the flying cars never came
until now
this is the doroni H1
you really do look like you're flying a
very large drone very very cool Daron
murdinger is the founder and CEO of
doroni Aerospace he started developing
the flying car just seven years ago when
I was stuck at a traffic jam like most
of us I saw this kid playing with a
drone and I said you know here we have a
flying car coming you know because it's
based on the same technology so how fast
would these go in their first iteration
so uh 100 miles will be the cruising
hard miles per hour the cruising in 120
is the max speed well just comfortable
you know cruising nicely what is it made
out of carbon fiber and electronics
basically a batteries uh cells mostly
the carbon fiber the concern a lot of
people have with anything electric is
how far it will ultimately go people see
these cool you know flying cars and they
think oh I can go across country but
what's the reality
so at this point unfortunately you
cannot but down their own definitely we
see this as the future price tag I see
this and I think who could ever afford
this what do you see this originally uh
costing so this point is about 300 it
will go to 375 000
our goal is to democratize it to make it
accessible we'll try to find the best
way to do listing whatever we can so
people can afford it because we we know
this is the future the first time you
got it off the ground what did that feel
like wow it was amazing the feeling is
really sitting in cushions of air I mean
I mean you have fans throwing air below
and you you're comfortable the inside of
the doroni H1 is actually really
spacious and it looks more like a
cockpit or maybe part of a video game
console than the front seat of a car
what are we looking at in these screens
okay so now what we see is the system
run Diagnostics basically check the
batteries the temperature
the voltage all the information we need
we're in that mean you're ready to take
off so let's say I want to go at 300
feet okay and it will start just Auto
takeoff
and it will take off just go up like
this straight up okay so I'm the pilot
you're the passenger uh-oh what do I do
so you're going forward like this just
going forward
yeah backwards
you can hear it already there's a lot of
play in this stick just a joystick just
very simple so for all the kids that are
video game aficionados this is going to
be second nature very easy for intuitive
to use yeah
oh my gosh
oh my gosh I wish my son were here
this is so cool let's say heaven forbid
one of the fans goes out or two or three
something potentially catastrophic what
about
safety precautions right so all together
we have eight vertical fans so we design
it in a way that in case of one or two
Network the system is a self-stabilized
if they all go up we have a ballistic
parachute that will deploy and will land
the whole aircraft what this guy doesn't
have but roads do are lights stop signs
gas and charging stations all things
needed in order to travel safely how
would it actually
work in terms of multiple vehicles on
the road so we try to to take to
understand the three-dimensional world
with from a two-dimensional world but
doesn't really work that way because we
have multiple of layers everyone can
choose his own you know altitude in a
way and and then interact with each
other because it's all digital how high
would these be flying so we can reach
out reach out to about ten thousand
eight thousand but the comfortable zone
is a couple of hundred feet just last
month the FAA released something and
called an implementation plan for these
types of vehicles and put in place new
training requirements for Pilots
regulation of this industry is probably
just beginning what do you feel about
that so we can learn from other
countries we have them in Brazil we have
in Australia in Europe they're all aware
of this technology coming to fruition
right now from our understanding it's
you can fly up to eight thousand ten
thousand feet and you can fly almost
everywhere beside going into major
airports this seems like an Elon Musk
project to me if I had to think of a
project that Elon Musk would be
interested in this kind of seems like it
we are happy to collaborate we are very
interested to get the big guys working
with us and we feel this is just a
starting point it's endless it's just
endless what is going with it thank you
that was a lot of fun Deron murtinger
and the whole gang there thank you so
much hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else